all right the lesson this week politics
is a game that turns players into
monsters and monsters into players when
Diane Feinstein got dr. Ford's
allegation she was a player but rather
than hold a private meeting about these
allegations which would have protected
the families and lives of both Cavanaugh
and Ford Feinstein sat on it until it
could only become a show trial one held
in honor of Merrick garland and here's
the key part it normalized collateral
damage you know what collateral damage
is you drop a bomb and innocent people
die the mob in that room knew their bomb
would destroy reputations humiliate a
family scar to could kids but they did
the math politically collateral damage
was worth it
so they unleashed the public accusations
leaking to accomplices something
Feinstein couldn't quite deny with
conviction because in the end the Ford
letter went from Feinstein to the media
my son doesn't know how this happened
how could it she investigated right
there on camera can you tell us that
your staff did not leak it oh I don't
believe my staff would leak it I have
not asked that question directly but you
know that I mean how in the world did
that get in the hands of the of the
press the answer is no the staff have
you asked have you asked your staff or
other staff dance or the Judiciary
Committee
pardon me well Jennifer reminds me I've
asked her before about it well so that's
true well somebody leaked it if it
wasn't you well it was I'm telling you
it was not I did not Oh
Farah Singh we're all in a mystery call
it transubstantiation but for sure it
was a miracle one created one that
created a hell no one would want to
endure happily for Feinstein and Friends
the target still entered the Coliseum
this is way bigger than he said she said
this is we said due process replaced by
political vigilantes presumption of
innocence be damned yesterday we saw a
mob seeking payback tribalism trumping
institutions and common sense a female
victim gets used a wife mother and
daughter are wounded
perhaps permanently America gets sick
while Feinstein holds a pitchfork and
says who me good he's good good do you
know what you know this was so
manufactured is where Alyssa Milano was
sitting over there to the I think
directly to the over Cavanaugh shoulder
she was the guest of doctor of Fine
Stein so and she was smiling and texting
and it's like why was she there that was
orchestrated this was a show trial
yeah show trial that had the intended
effect yes look where we are today
mm-hmm you had a situation where when he
came back when Cavanaugh came back off
the ropes yeah someone talked to him at
lunchtime after dr. Ford's testimony
said listen dude you want this job you
get out there and you fight for this job
he got up with using that boxing analogy
he went back out there and he swung and
he did it he had the momentum he who got
back on top he was heading toward
cruising toward that nomination then
Jeff Flake happened right I'm a
University of Arizona beer damn
graduates yep flat cap yeah
so the Jeff Lake happened and for anyone
as a former activist attorney myself if
you think that there was those noisy
demonstrators have no impact other than
making a nuisance them felt you should
take talk to the two ladies who
confronted Jeff Flake in that elevator
they made history
they made him he's not it doesn't seem
like the strongest there rod in the shed
anyway he collapsed then they had no
choice there's no choice Lindsey Graham
says it didn't come from the leak came
from Feinstein should there be an
investigation well then I think the
prosecutor yesterday did a really nice
job establishing the chain of custody
for this letter she said it's either
Ford personally and she gave it to the
congresswoman Democrat and then it went
to Feinstein those are the only three
people that had cuts out of it the leak
must have come from them and if you look
at this woman Ford yesterday incredibly
riveting very compelling obviously
believable personally but she's
incredibly naive she's an academic she's
you know a little bit she seemed a
little out of it at times and she has
been manipulated by the Senate Democrats
in the Judiciary Committee and by her
lawyers and the prosecutor did an
excellent job
explaining that and here's how the whole
flying thing afraid of flying that was
manufactured they showed that she goes
to Hawaii she goes all over the country
she had just flown back and forth across
the east and west coast so that was like
it was also established that she never
even heard right the invitation to come
interview her on the west coast her
lawyers were keeping that from her is
that a lie that B isn't that against the
the truth well no it couldn't been the
lawyers be in trouble from with other
things yeah I mean you don't have to
tell your client everything Geraldo
would know more but it seemed like she
had no idea that that offer was
proffered and then the the the polygraph
was very bizarre that they did it on the
same day she had gone to her mother's
funeral and she kinda they won't release
any of the audio and the video from the
polygraph and the the sex crimes
prosecutor again but made a great point
at the very end in closing and said this
is not how you treat a true victim of
sexual assault or sick interview and you
don't polygraph her up and lawyer up and
then parade her out on national
television these people like you said in
the monologue
white watching Ford being tortured
rights watching Kavanagh being tortured
it was sadistic what they did there was
all of those things but it was also
premeditated yeah you don't have to be
guessing around but Democrats that come
back to this point the Democrats which
represent the pro-choice forces in this
country they were holding the weak hand
the pro-life forces represented by the
Republicans holding in the stronger hand
they're Democrats desperate what do we
do aha they get the golden ticket the
golden ticket in the form of the doctor
Ford accusations how are we going to use
this to the best effect we're gonna hold
it we're gonna hold it we're gonna look
like we're losing when this first came
up no we're holding the vote on Monday
we're not extending it's a Thursday for
a hearing
that's the are playing games if he had
done that it would have avoided this
delay and it would not have jeopardized
this vote it's if you think he could
have played that you think you would
have suffered I think you think it looks
like they're not willing to hear from
women about sexual assault which is a
playbook that Democrats have been using
for decades
been using it in political campaigns
midterm presidential four years that
would have not been optically a good
look now the consequences of that I do
want to say about dianne feinstein
dropping this bomb into the middle of
the committee her staff and senator
grassley staff used to actually have a
pretty good relationship they used to
have a really professional working
relationship when it comes to important
big issues like protecting
whistleblowers national security
oversight of government agencies and she
has completely destroyed any kind of
relationship that they had in the past
as the left continues to lecture the
right about civility and coming together
and washington working to make sure
we're bettering the country she
destroyed that relationship it was a
good one and she has a lot of explaining
to do and as Greg mentioned there
shouldn't be an investigation so
Feinstein doing this because she's in
trouble too it with the left in
California this is big you have to go
back to this I was a young lawyer when
roe v wade was argued and passed this
was a sea change this was an incredibly
profound women in the streets the first
lap of the women's movement was
happening unfolding the nation was
beginning to fracture along these lines
this is the generation later the
pro-life forces finally had an
opportunity to to sway things back their
way a generation later and this is the
fight to the finish this is any means
you could acknowledge that if you can
say this is this is political this is
about abortion then can't you see that
no matter how many investigations you do
there's always going to be something
else always something else I agree so
you can't just keep calling for
investigations of uncorroborated claims
because this is political and Cavanaugh
said it was political which they hate
him for yeah they said it was revenge he
was willing to come out Slash's claims
they play dirty with Merrick garland now
what goes right this I don't see like
that I don't think that you could
actually predict or say that with this
Supreme Court nomination anything
happens to roe v wade I think that's a
game and it's
so I don't think that it's under threat
garage I do I do it's I'll tell you very
easily very very quickly roe v wade said
there's a competing interest mother and
unborn child at some point the child
becomes viable when the child can live
outside the mother of the child now has
the rights of a human that bed date gets
keeps getting pushed back six months
five months four months into the
pregnancy nine you get will be the
technology they'll use technology to
sonogram showing that a baby's real
thing the message we're giving is that
you can derail a nomination if you don't
like the policy and it's being allowed
it's being tolerated all right now